-We love our audience.
You watch us every night,
but right now we want to change
things up and watch you.
We asked you guys at home
to send us some fun or unique
talents that you have.
We got submissions
from thousands of people
all across the world.
And we're going to meet
some of them right now.
It's time for
"Show Me Something Good."
♪ -Show me something good ♪
♪ Show me something good,
show me something good ♪
♪ Just show me ♪
-Alright.
Let's meet our first guest.
Hello. What is your name
and where are you from?
-Hey, Jimmy, I'm Jemima June and
I'm from Nashville, Tennessee.
-Yeah, I love Nashville!
Hi, Jemima.
Nashville, Tennessee.
Welcome to the show.
Jemima, what talent will you
be sharing with us tonight?
-I can open five beer bottles
in less than three seconds.
-Five -- In less than
three seconds?
Alright, now we're talking.
Here we go. That's a talent.
Roots, can we get a drumroll,
please?
[ Drumroll ]
[ Bottles clanking ]
What?
Alright, whenever you're ready.
Go.
Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
What?
Yo!
What?!
You are awesome!
What was --
That was unbelievable!
Can we see that again
in slow mo?
[ Cheers and applause ]
The accuracy. The accuracy.
-I actually forgot
the sixth one.
-Oh, come on!
That's how --
That's a mike drop.
Hey, you're awesome.
Thank you for
that incredible talent.
I appreciate you
being on the show.
Thank you very much.
That's cool, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's meet our next guest.
Hello. What is your name
and where are you from?
-Hi, I'm Mark.
I'm from Toronto.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We love -- Hi to everybody
in Toronto.
Shout-out to Bloor Street.
Hey, Mark, what is your talent
that you'll be showing us
tonight?
-My talent is I play
the clarinet and the piano
at the same time.
[ Audience murmurs ]
-And what song were you going
to be playing for us, Mark?
-I'm going to play
one of my own songs.
-Yeah, perfect. I love it.
Whenever you're ready.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yo, thank you very much
for that, Mark.
Do you have a title
for that song?
-"Happy Go Lucky."
-There you go.
That's my man right there.
I appreciate you being
on the show, Mark.
That's a good talent.
Thank you very much.
Let's meet our final guest
right here.
Oh, hey, guys.
What are your names
and where are you from?
-Hi, Jimmy. My name is Andie,
and this is my boyfriend Dylan.
-Hi, Dylan.
-We're from St. Louis, Missouri.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey!
St. Louis!
Shout-out to
Crown Candy Kitchen.
Thank you for being on the show.
What talent will you be
showing us tonight?
-So, I'm pretty good at
catching shrimp in my mouth.
And my boyfriend is going to be
my hibachi chef,
and he's going on throw them
and we're going to see
if I can catch them.
[ Laughter ]
-Yep. Say it again.
So you're pretty good at
catching shrimp in your mouth?
And your boyfriend,
you're going to flip the shrimp?
Are you good at flipping shrimp?
-No.
-Okay. Alright, perfect.
So you are -- you're going to
flip shrimp.
How did you learn that you have
this talent?
-Growing up, my family would
always love going to
get hibachi together,
and at a young age I learned
that this was one of
my secret, hidden talents.
And I warned him
when we started dating.
[ Laughter ]
-To the dying end.
-Well, alright.
You're going to go for it.
See if you can catch
as many shrimp as you can.
Drumroll please there, Quest.
[ Drumroll ]
This is exciting.
Alright.
-Okay.
-Whenever you're ready.
Oh, my gosh. One.
♪♪
Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Yeah, oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, good job.
Very impressive.
Great job flipping, by the way.
Oh, my God! Well done!
Well done! Very good.
Very talented.
That's all the time we have
for "Show Me Something Good."